there was a time when a new monarch came
to Westminster hall for their coronation
banquet complete with Knight in armor
today it's just handshakes and a cup of
tea the most here aren't invited on
Saturday I've got to say this was
amazing isn't it the king came to
Parliament and Parliament came out the
king and I'm going to say the sheer
numbers staff members of parliament
Pierce we were all here everybody who
wanted to be part of the coronation and
this was his gift to Paul up myself I
will Camille and he did the king in good
spirits with just days to go before his
coronation
but still plenty more preparation
especially for the Archbishop of
Canterbury who's leading the service and
will Crown the king I'm very conscious
of what a huge privilege it is to do it
and we've been doing lots of rehearsals
since February and you know it's slowly
coming together
also coming together visiting foreign
leaders as they're met by the king from
his own family a rare Insight with the
Princess Royal in interview discussing
the monarchy's relevance I think it's in
it perfectly true that it it is a moment
where you need to have that discussion
but I would just underline the that the
monarchy provides with the Constitution
a degree of long-term
stability that it's actually quite hard
to come by any other way and as for
slimming things down well I think the
slim Dan was was said in a day when
there were a few more people around make
that seem like a justifiable right a
comment the world changes a bit it
changes a bit I mean it doesn't sound
like a good idea from where I'm standing
I have to say
Princess Anne has an honorary role at
the coronation procession
[Music]
and to that she'll be joined by
thousands of troops who are now making
their way into London Laura bundock Sky
News